the Russo brothers just came by and they
said they did not give you a script
Ruffalo didn't even get a script
understand it's like doing them a favor
because it's it's hard to keep secret
it's hard to keep your mouth closed I
got a script but it was a dummy
there was scenes in there that I have I
thought we were shooting that nobody
ever shot how much did he tell you
nothing I don't know they know no I know
not honestly like I I don't having and I
don't all right here's our match to do
stare into the camera blink once if you
live blink twice if you die just stare
straight ahead if you can't tell me
anything it hurt your eyes okay here's
what I have to know are you your kid's
favorite Avenger Black Panther now yeah
that's that's kind of that's kind of
Captain America so it is tough when
you're kids were like yeah we like that
other guy
yeah but they also take me to they'll
always love me they're like you're not
getting fired are you dad are you
finally ready to see this movie that
every the world has waited for and the
explosion that will happen once
everybody sees it instantly people go
crazy I've been dying to see it we had a
chance to see it yesterday but I held
off because I want to see it with an
audience I want to be I want to be in
that experience with you guys
yeah that's that's and that's when it
really means something so you get to see
it together yeah our kids are here too
and 6000 Los Angelenos
friends of yours other friends of you by
the way did you know that BRE was in 13
going on 30
oh my god
that's amazing it's her does she talk
about that yeah what'd she say we're
together no that's how she learned she
wanted to be a director one day because
she loved all the stuff going on and she
learned that she wanted to stay in the
business and yeah it was a Gary Winnick
director that rest in peace Gary yeah
that was a that was a lovely little
movie come to et you learn something new
today
yeah thank you man that's you guys you
do this more often
we're learning we're learning
[Music]